let's get started
um next talk is going to be on Max set
related uh by Nina you know yeah
um yes so in this talk I was going to
talk about the analysis of course
using course and correction sets uh this
is a work we've done with Nikolai last
year and presented at saat
um and then the second part of the talk
I was going to talk about uh
some
ideas how we thought we can get some
insights from this series this paper is
a theoretical paper so we thought maybe
we can gain some ideas from the
theoretical paper and try to build a
better solver
um
it turns out to be very hard uh I did
multiple attempts uh most of them
unsuccessful and maybe the last of them
was partially successful and we are
working on this now with Emir and
his students influence Martin
uh but when we went through this journey
of uh trying to build up a new solver
using some mutations from our
theoretical results and what econom was
telling uh telling us is tweaking and
non-science uh we it really his talk is
really resonated because it's something
that we just recently uh went through
and I thought that maybe not everyone in
this audience is trying to tweak the
sorrowful competition so kind of a
change of talk and
um most of the talk out I will present
uh the way how yet
tweaking this over how we're trying to
look what's going on instance but by
instance and see whether we can gain any
insights and improve the solar and take
all this entertainment Journey because
Carl was saying that we are not doing
science when we are picking the solver
but we are doing an entertainment so uh
first I'll present our surgical results
and on this state I'll present the uh
settings and state the results but most
of the talk will be about this
entertainment Journey how we take
observations a lot of massive data and
trying to tweak the solve
so um I'll start with some background we
already had a few talks on max out so
very briefly
um the most General formulation it's
weighted partial Max art problem where
we have um heart closes so closes that
we have to satisfy and soft Clauses C1
to CN
uh those are soft closets we can violate
them and every time we violate the close
we pay a cost
repair cost W so for equivalency one we
pay cos W1
uh here we uh we'll be focusing on a
special case where always a one partial
max out so always a one because every
every close value violation costs one I
will just remove weight so we'll just
count number of related clause
is to find an assignment that satisfies
all hard Clauses right because we can't
realize them they have infinite cost and
while it's the minimum number of
softballs so we want to relate as little
as possible
so as people were developing solvers uh
they came up with useful Notions that
characterize why problem is inconsistent
why there is no solution which cost zero
so the first notion is unsatisfiable
four we already saw unsatisfiable course
in many talks over this week
so unsatisfiable core it's a subset of
the Clauses of the formula that is
already unsatisfiable no matter what the
other Clauses are
and usually in Microsoft solving we are
interested in minimal not minimal but
Moraine was talking yesterday what we
know but these are minimal unsatisfiable
versus you can't drink anymore
uh so here
um
I put our running example
so suppose you have a problem uh where
we have eight causes from C1 to C8 and I
will not pull out this Clause but
suppose we also know all minimum
unsatisfiable success of this formula we
know all minimal course and I show them
using a hypograph notation so now we
have a hypergraph where you have one
every Clause represent a node in this
graph and every
um H represents a core so we know that
C1 and C3 together former core so they
together can't be satisfied and this
structure in this hypergraph we will
refer in the talk as a core structure
so the next Notions and Notions the
heating set and we will Define it with
respect to uh course so if we say have a
set of course let's say in this example
a set of two cores uh we uh hitting set
the subset of course that hits every
core so example here will be C6 and C7
because it's a subset of course that
hits every core we have two cores in
this example
so related Notions and notion of a
correction set
correction set is a subset of closer
size that if you remove them from the
formula
it becomes satisfied
so correction correction set is a
heating set of all Muses of all minimal
unsatisfiable subsets
so in in our example
we have five ports so any correction set
has to hit every single course so here
here one example of the correction set
you have C1 C4 and C6 and this will be
correction step because I hit every
single core
right and um it's well known that the
minimum correction said it's minimum
heating set of all
minimal cores
okay now I'll talk about a theoretical
results so there are um two we're
talking about complete Max science there
were a few talks talking about
incomplete Max as this is a complete uh
where you when you've finished you
produce the optimal solution and there
are two classes of solvers uh that
considered to be state-of-the-art
solvers and also in the community they
considered to be like a difference over
so they work based on the different
uh
um ideas and algorithms are very
different and the way how they operate
is very different
so we will use this um analogy one
heating set by solvers we will use we'll
call it like a Curious George and for
the core guided we will call it Tom
because uh to reflect how this uh
algorithms works with a formal so you
have an input formula file and you have
the same formula is given to each
algorithm and the way how they solve it
is very very different so Curious George
uh it will take the formula it will look
at it it will start it it will gradually
step by step retrieve the core structure
of the formal and in the end it rise to
the optimal solution
is working it's very different it just
destroys the formula every step or while
the server progress it rewrites the
formula uh formula becomes harder and
harder in the end if we manage to
terminate the solvent but the formula is
really different from the one that you
started with
that's why um kind of common knowledge
in the community was that these two
approaches are very different and what
we were actually showing in this paper
that implicitly Tom looking for the same
things as a Curious George's working so
they're actually retrieving the same
core structure but one is doing it
explicitly and another one implicitly so
to make it more clear I will explain how
this algorithms operate
so we start with the heating base solar
we I don't see any of the talks
presented to solvers like a formally yes
the Germany gave a good talk and he
outlined how they were but I will not go
to deeply into details but to some
extent explain how they work
so okay how they work um so we have a
formula a formula has a core structure
but it's a ground truth it's not known
right for the solver all the solver
notes it's a formula with a set of
Clauses somewhere is there there is a
core structure but in the beginning we
don't know anything about it and also
here I will have a trace while a solo
progress it collects certain objects and
this I put in the tricks so at the
beginning
um hitting step by solver or curatorial
solo so it's very optimistic it says
Okay can they find the solution satisfy
all the Clauses and it has the satsora
uh an answer will be no why no because
there is a core right so the sad solver
will return it okay you can't satisfy
all the all the closer there is a call
she's seven see it so you see this is a
ground truth and this is my knowledge of
the ground rule so now I only know about
one or so then Curious George says okay
I know about One chord let me find the
minimum teaching set of this core of
what I know and maybe by luck this is
actually minimum interesting set of
entire formal so it does what it can
right it only knows about one chord it
finds a heating set so maybe a C7 it
will be heating set for the score
uh it removes the score from the formula
and us again that starts over okay
can they now satisfied
and the answer will be no right because
we we have to hit every single core and
uh with removing of the vocals we
couldn't do it so the salsa will say no
and why because I give you another chord
now my knowledge a little bit more right
so now the solver knows about two cores
of the formula
so again we do our best we try to find
the minimum heating set here and New
Heating
that here will be C8 again one right so
we didn't improve our bound we still
know that it's only heating set is only
that we can show of size one it will be
C8
so if we try again how we remove C8 from
the formula and we keep going we will
find the new core and eventually it will
discover the core structure not not know
that it doesn't mean to know about all
possible course of the formula it will
discover some of them but it will be
enough for it to produce a solution or
mean teaching set of the score that will
be optimal solution
to recap so what the solver is doing it
works as a regional formula it doesn't
realize the formula you just keep it as
is gradually discover the core structure
and at the end it guarantees that
minimum hitting set of all discovered
cores it's optimal cost equal to the
optimal cost
okay this is what what's how uh heating
pressovers operate
so how the core guided operate
surface they operate in a very different
way so Tom starts with the formula it
doesn't try to discover construction it
doesn't care about the core structure it
feels they all start the same they start
optimistic cannot satisfy all the uh all
the soft quarters the answer is no
and the witness would be equal so what
Thomas doing it takes the score and it
rewrites the formula so it introduces
new variables so called relaxation
variables it adds to the each clause in
the core and it's cardinality
constraints
foreign
the core we know that all of them can't
be satisfied together right
communication
so we have a C1 C3 to C70 closes right
closes of the original formula so it may
be X or Y right
so we have some codes that didn't spell
out uh them maybe we have C1 and C2
right and C1 equal to X and C2 is not X
right we know that it's unsatisfiable
it's a chord
that's always
the format that you wrote down there's
the exactly one of the of yeah exactly
one exactly one of them must be must be
one because it's a relaxation variable
okay
right so you see that now formal is
Rewritten
so and we go to the next iteration one
interesting thing that happens here that
course of this formula change so these
are not course of original formula and
not course of this formula this will be
new course
right so as you progress we change the
formula and then changes the course
automatically change
so again okay this is formal satisfiable
still contains some course
so sad soul will give them the new new
core
and it will relax again introducing new
variables and cardinality constraints
and it keeps going concept it changes
the formula of course changing and
introducing cardinality constraints and
then because of what we are doing we're
relaxing the formula and then we write
the formula which is satisfiable
but this formula is completely written
as we progress formal becomes harder and
harder because we relax course we
introduce cardinality constraints
so high level what is going on
um
this solver works with with relaxed
formula so it relax on every step it
discovers course of the relaxed formula
and when it terminates formally
satisfiable so and we'll find the
optimal we find the Optimal Solutions as
many steps we did it's actually a value
of the optimal solution
but you know because everything it's a
corner it was very confusing we have
course of original formula we have this
course over the written Clauses that are
generated as a by uh product of uh of
core guidance so so we had to introduce
a new notation we called uh foremost of
relaxed uh course meta in the paper so
those are met why we call it method
because actually they are kind of a meta
course they contains a lot of course of
the original form
okay so if you look at these two traces
that one produced so one one algorithms
produce course of original formula just
revealing the structure another one
produces this methods with cardinality
constraints they look very different but
we had the paper earlier showing that
there is also implicit rates that you
can extract from the core guidance over
execution
and I won't go into detail because I
want to talk more about practical
considerations but what it says this
paper says that you can start from this
trace and produce somewhat equivalent
Trace we didn't know this equivalent but
now we know but so we can produce a
trace in terms of the course of original
form so it's a procedure that shows how
from this meta core generate course of
original formal so we already knew that
you can go from methods to the course of
original formula
so what then the main result of the
paper we look at this course we know
that course at core
um heating sets over generated nice they
have this property on the heating set
but we don't know what this implicit uh
Trace course how good they generate some
codes how good this course up so we
decided to analyze properties
of this generated course and we were
focusing on a new heating set the main
result of the paper says that
if you get this all course the three
generated as an implicit trace and
compute the minimum heating set of it
it's actually menu hitting set equal to
the optimal solution Yeah question was
there some reason you picked the first
for Tom to be different from the
first core form no it doesn't matter it
was just easier for neutral okay it's
worse for any execution it's a very kind
of massive proof but it says it in any
execution if you collect this meta
course and we have a procedure how to go
from meta course to course of original
formula at the end if you collect all of
them
if you find the new heating set it will
be
um
equal meaning said scientific heating
set equal to the optimal solution
right so this was in addition uh this
was actually what Karen called I guess
time so we did proven
but this is not our kind the final goal
our final goal is to
um build the solar so even in the paper
we discussed how this results can first
of all right result is interesting and
how we can maybe build a better solar so
why result is interesting
so this is the first results that shows
that actually there's so much internally
they are not that much different both of
them are the explicitly or implicitly
work on the core structures the core
structure of a regional formula and they
extract very good course
and also we pointed out that um the
scores you generate because when a core
guidance over stopped okay you have an
optimal solution what's the proof if we
can generate the course that I just
described it can be alternative
certificate to show why optimal cost
you know
it will be certificate for the optimal
cost right because all of them are
course of original formula and meme
hitting set of them equals to this
thread
right so what
now we're going to practical
considerations
uh so we saw the key if you have this
Insight that this solvers all generate
course they all work with a core
structure of the formula maybe we can
somehow you know build the hybrid solo
we can run one solo for some time maybe
maybe it's stuck at some point we get
all the codes to produce give it to a
different solver and maybe exchange
between them
so now we're going on our entertainment
journey of
struggling to build the soul and in the
end we still we don't have a best
performing solver out of this results
so okay so let's start looking the very
basic things to try we start with the
heating set solver run it for some time
you write to some bomb
maybe a silver can't progress anymore
you collect all the course that we know
by this point give it somehow the core
guidance over and hopefully you would
start from the low banking how to do it
this was our research question is
actually not very clear and we even
simplify a problem over more so let's
not forget about kicking sets forward
let's imagine we have a core generation
Oracle someone in Oracle gives you a
core structure approximation of the core
structure can you take advantage of it
foreign
so what we did we run we took instances
from last year uh maxat evaluation much
it doesn't allow me to say competition
so we have to say evaluation
so
so from from the start evaluation and
for for each instance for we only were
looking for unweighted one just purely
because we don't have resources and
um we run a core extraction procedure
greedy heavily randomized construction
procedure for six hours and this was our
quarter generation Oracle and then we
have for each instance now we have a lot
of course of original formal can we can
we now make a solver somehow take
advantage of this course
so we're on for six hours on each
instance we collect all the cores we
minimize but procedure to minimize the
course it's it's a heuristic so in the
in the end we don't know is of course a
minimal or not and results are noisy
mostly because uh they were not attended
you know the resulted
when I was doing the test it's for
internal use but we talked to Emir uh
yesterday and we thought maybe we can
make it public so people also work on it
um so the goal is can we learn something
from the core structure and know that
this results are solvers Independence so
it doesn't matter we just look at the
instance core structure try to observe
something and maybe based on these
observations uh improve the soul
so we'll have um
two types of observations the first type
of observation is a instance double
observation so this is the first
instance that they'll show actually will
be always showing two instances from the
same family and this is a histogram so
on the x-axis we show course size so a
generator out of course here I show like
in each each histogram will correspond
to chord of circumcise so here course of
size 25
and on the y-axis I show how many cores
of this size is it clear because we'll
be using histogram right so uh and on
top um for for two instances from the
same family uh I just give some
statistics um like a number of variables
number of clothes
number of heart Clauses number of
variables number of soft codes in this
formula and for the reference I give you
time to solve for a good solver not the
best solver there but the pretty good
form
okay so if you have instance like that
you generated this course and
you have this observation so all the
course that the heuristic never
generated outside of the same size and
there are a lot of them
would you be able to conclude something
about this instance
right so what does it mean we have 25
soft Clauses every time I sample because
sorry we have 55 we have 55
soft clothes right
and every time it seems to be right
because it's heuristic how we generate
core we sample 25 of them maybe
four and so on 25
number
25 of them
and this is a core
any ideas what just what this formula
yeah
foreign
maybe you have a cardinality constraint
hiding in there but I have a question so
I mean what course you're when you're
extracting these chords should I think
of you as as running like some kind of
implicit things that's all because which
course you're gonna see is gonna depend
on which assumptions you write okay so
and you didn't tell us this or did you I
didn't use APC seating set for purpose
because I wanted to have a good um
good grasp what the core structure
overall I don't know what um but how are
you going to get different core I mean
you need some assumptions for your
solver so yes so I remember my
consumptions uh I uh it's a very simple
greedy heavy randomized algorithms the
only thing that I ensure that every time
if I manage to generate the core it's a
new core okay but uh yes
this is the total number of course
extracted right it's not in any way
minimized it's not like we need this
many course to to we no we don't try to
now we're just analyzing what we get so
in six hours actually six or eight but
for a long time around this uh greedy
prestigious ingredients procedure to
generate the score by no means it's all
course it's just some big sample but if
you have 200 200 000 cores of the same
size randomly kind of sample it might
already suggest something
right yes and this actually
right because if you look at the title
of this benchmark this is a benchmark
name
you see at most 24 out of 25.
so we can of course go and try to hope
that Benchmark names gives us hints
which is I don't think but um also like
even if it's uh what the current
referred as tweaking or kind of um
nonsense entertainment it actually can
gives you some you know intentions and I
think it's very similar but Jeremiah
suggested in in his paper a few years
ago right he he has a he didn't it's a
different way but I think conception is
exactly the same so it what my point is
and you probably were also staring at
benchmarks right
so I think it's a counter example to
what Karen was saying that just uh
staring and data in the instance by
instance trying to tune this over
doesn't give you uh
good intuition but this is sometimes uh
they're actually quite interesting okay
so the next instance
so all Plus in the first block will be
the same so we have core sizes on the
x-axis and number of course of this size
on the y-axis
so what to observe here okay so this is
what I'm telling now it's not by any
means a ground throws anything it just
as a human a solo developer observations
and you might have others
so it was the one that I observed so
first of all let's look at this instance
so the number one there are two
instances the two instances from the
same class
number of Clauses they're slightly
different but it's Millions so um I
would say they're not that much
different and a number of soft scores
about the same
but also notice the time to solve the uh
this instance is very very different
right so one you can solve the orange
one you can solve almost in no time and
another one takes
quite a bit of time time and seconds
time to solve
and my point here is that looking at the
variables a number of Clauses that Karen
presented uh a few days ago as a you
know in some of the key things that we
can keep track of for instances and uh
see how different solvers perform but
then it's not sufficient at least for
Microsoft because given two instances
that have about this I'm not sure about
the Primal graph maybe graphs can be
different but I I I doubt that too much
different but if you look at the number
of course you can clearly see that one
problem most likely will be harder than
another so you see this blue problem has
way more course of size six way more
course of size seven and eight so just
by looking at the structure
you
of the course of the basic statistic of
the course you can get some insights
on
um
how how difficult is problems
um why you put this instance that
actually
for those instances knowing that this
course in advance improves the solver so
for those instances I could get an
improvement
why because core sizes are smooth
but they'll talk about four seconds late
okay number three so again it's two
inches might be the same instances but
permuted from this family look those are
very small number of variables number of
Clauses and number of softs and it's
either times out of uh can't solve it or
cancel it very close to the timeout and
look at the core structure so
do you think this Pro for those who are
familiar with core guided uh they think
it's a hard problem for core guided or
easy
like I think the key he has to look at
the core sizes you know if course are
large what does it mean that when you
relax the chord you have introduced very
large cardinality constraints
so just
knowing
that there are so many cores and most of
them are somewhat larger course
hints that for
um core guided so it will be tough
instance
and then we go to even more extreme like
that it's another instance you see the
core sizes is uh 400 goes from so even
without running the silver I can tell
you that uh silver will never terminate
on this instance
because Corsa gigantic and also know
that
um
this course is large more than 100.
so
it's kind of it's a useful it's not as
nice as abstract corsage nautical
strands that you can take uh you can
just observe and maybe use to improve
your saw over here you just look at it
okay
there are a large course and they're not
easy and what to do with it you can only
have like a hybrid
what to do with it no I'm just curious
is it like would you say it's a general
phenomenon if you have like many large
cores that that would be like based on
your experience where implicit hitting
set would Shine for instance compared to
Korea I don't know
and this problem I I don't know actually
I don't have limitation I I doubt it's
also very much depends what the minion
heating set of this course if it's high
I'm not even sure that heating set rule
I think no one solves this instance in
the competition because mean teaching
set of this course it's high it's 100
and I don't know it's low bound this
means he said Slow buttons optimal
solution absolute high so it was such a
huge number of large pores a heating set
will not be able to solve it what you're
saying at least you believe that like
corrugated will die simply because yeah
the number of variables that you're very
quickly yes it will it will progress a
little bit inside it can't do 100 steps
conduit relaxation with course because
course size grows this is a real course
of original formula right because when
you start doing relaxation scores become
even larger
yep
then in this case it's probably unit
Clauses so all the source codes the unit
clauses
it looks like every soft clause
has a unique one of the unique variable
I mean there's a one-to-one
correspondence yes yes so then it means
that also of course are unit closes
units
right one more example
um
okay so another instance uh
why
well this is instant is very large
so number of water bosses large number
of course is large not that many softs
um and
timed out so sober times out
but you see that we we found a lot of
course and they have small size
so for for these instances
we also managed to now it's a question
was that you can improve the solver
knowing in advance about the core
structure is or understand at least
something there so here because all
course are small
initial course so you can Traverse them
in a certain order like against the
heuristic but you can
improve you can solve this intensive
knowing this construction advance and
exploiting it but there is nothing
General here you just look at it and see
what uh
what you can do
okay so another thing it's kind of a I
would say pathological case so um
again we have two instances from the
same family uh and all course of size
one all courses in front of size one so
it means that this formula
even
all the cores in this formula of size
one unit course
so it means that I'm not even sure
whether
such instances are good candidate for
maxat evaluation because it's a
competition of the sad solvers right you
find one you need four you relax it you
find the new conco you remove course you
will of course not along the kind of
removed from the formal so if you know
that you have
all the course of you of size one or the
course the unit in this sampling
procedure
maybe it can be removed from the maxat
evaluation because it's not you don't
need anything from maxata from maxat
algories to solve this problem you just
need a very fast uh start solver
and
the silver who will win on this type of
businesses will be the ones that have a
better sad soul
right um another example
so it's kind of an example showing that
all these analysis that I was talking
about can be completely misleading
so we have a in other
family I don't know what it means like
to to
um two instances pretty small the number
of variables a small number of poses
number of source solved
and um
the answer is something you know this
greedy sampling procedure of this course
is actually it's a blind procedure it
gives a formula and it generates
whatever uh and we obtain the result
that all the courses you find were of
size three
but look how many of them for example
for for this uh orange instance there
are about
um three thousand
something uh course but actually what's
going on look at this number of Clauses
it's exactly the number or almost close
to the number of course what it means
that you have a lot of hard Clauses that
contains only soft
um
so it also also of course say units so
it means that all the hard clothes are
effectively coarse so you're just
recreating the instance
you you can't do this is a wasted effort
right because what what all what you
already created it's hard uh with this
course it's a hard uh cost of the
original formula
when all course of the same size we can
make some conclusions not always the
case here it's useless because we just
recreated the formal we didn't learn
anything you know
okay so I have uh fighting I have
something
um so the next set of observation is a
kind of competition level observation so
we look at the all interesting the
competition and see how um try to
analyze overall like how would our core
generation procedure like is it
um was it maybe useful
so we actually filter out on all
instances that are sold by a reasonably
good solver in uh 600 seconds so we
filtered out all the easy instances
right um so what we are showing here
we're showing upload on um x axis we
have number of cores that we found per
instance and on y-axis we show average
core size for this instance it's
truncated it's actually there are
computers they have very large average
size uh 50 000 so I printed so what one
point means one point means that there
is an instance in the last year
evaluation that we managed to find maybe
like 80 000 cores and average size of
this course was um about 100
um
120 yes
so
mean of the point
how many course we found for this
instance and every size of the course so
there are a few observations here so
there are very few instances
that we can generate a huge number of
course and usually by the core size is
small
is there is a huge number of fields that
they have like a lesson uh 100
000 course generated and again this size
is small and very few uh that have very
large core signs and this partially
explains why core guided some of the
effective on these instances because uh
dealing with large courses very hard for
it and there are not that many there are
not that many instances that by the
sampling procedure of course we found
that
um
is large
right um in other points that we wanted
to understand how good is this core
structure so what what they mean again I
made up this notion of goodness what
does it mean but what they mean by it so
let's say this is our core structure and
if um our core enumeration procedure our
Oracle only found this course it's bad
right because uh
we hope to find to have a good
understanding of the all the course
landscape finding this course will be
okay but it's not very useful because
they all overlap or on one variable so
he can set as one
so so what what is this Plot show so
here on the X oh
so on the x-axis I show what is the best
low bound the core guided uh solver
could find in one hour and on the y-axis
it's a minimum it's the size of the mean
heating set of the chords that they
found
so what this point means so in this
point means that if I run good solver
for uh one hour I can get to the low
bound which is Maybe 80. but if I look
at all the chords that I found the
minion heating set of this course is
more than 100.
right so even running the best over for
long time will not even get me to the
point
okay this is not clear I look at Jacob
okay we have this course we can find the
minimum heating set of them this will be
a low amount of the optimal cost so if I
look at all the cores from this instance
they generate it low bound is 110. so
what is my goal a final goal if I know
that low bump already 110 I would like
to hot start somehow knowing all that
what start core guided solo with a
slowbone but actually it's very hard
well I don't know I didn't succeed to do
and we know that if we just run it on
its own it will not even get there it
will not even get 200 it will be at 90.
and look at this instance so this is the
instance
I think it's one that we saw before this
instance was a large course
so you have a lot of large cores
and uh you need a lot of relaxation so
you need at least 100 something
relaxation points to hit them then for
core guide that you see it doesn't go
anyway it stops less at less than 100
points
right so okay so to conclude
you probably already noticed that it's a
quite messy process to go through all
these statistics and trying to
understand what
uh looking at the instance and trying to
understand what the property is there
what we can learn from this data whether
we can improve the soul but I think I
hope I convince you that course are
actually very important objects and it
was it was known before that order in
which we find this course matter we know
that the for the solvers it's important
uh so if you find the right order
there's no definitions the right order
but if there is somewhere a good order
uh if you can find it solver is much
faster
or in this work we show that both
classes of solvers they explicitly or
implicitly generate the score structure
and also we know that I'm taking all of
them in just invisible there can be
exponential number of them it's just
gigantic so the best thing we can do is
something
um so the question if you have some time
for the discussion maybe a few few
minutes you have like I wanted to um
pause it um like if courses are so
important objection we study them
as a you know as a standalone
um
notion right it should be study this uh
core structure maybe we can't get the
whole course but we can get
approximation and uh by studying the
structure improve the solvers or maybe
even first understand what the property
of the instances and then improve the
solar
so what what do the uh what do people
think it's not necessarily people who
are doing Max uh Max I don't uh sad
people uh because for unsatisfiable
instances
maybe it's also useful to understand why
formula is hard by generating many many
unsatisfiable cores and then it will
also might tell you something about uh
weather actually uh
hardness of the problem is hidden
so any opinions on that
opinions
know how much
okay so any opinions in that
okay do people agree that it's important
to study core structure
yay
so at least when we have one yes that's
good and much runs competition so
I'm sorry we should cut it out from the
recording evaluation yeah
a small remarket in uh well other work
we've been doing uh we're interested in
finding course with specific properties
so this comes from
um originally from explaining
constrained programming instances and
we're searching actively for Cores that
have certain properties so maybe it can
be relevant here as well yeah
yeah I guess Southern Property is
important but I also think knowing the
entire landscape is also important
a very naive and online question not
related even to Mac said you could ask
like for the SAT competition you could
you could ask for unsatisfiable
instances about the core set and you
know distribution of course and if that
somehow correlates to you know the the
formulas that we solve quickly do they
have lots of cores or like or yes this
is what they thought also write it for
starting from start instances looking at
the core structure give you some
insights about a problem
what do you think because the course
that you considered were more or less
greatly obtained
um
do you think it's worth spending more
efforts into getting kind of high
quality course maybe looking at direct
proofs along the lines Marine talked
yesterday
it's definitely good to have a minimal
I don't know but it's always good to
have course right because maybe it's
only describes one part of the
inconsistency they might have other
parts which have very large course but
they're definitely good to have a
minimal one so maybe it will help to
minimize the quality I think he was
doing to speak English but he was
looking for the minimum right but the
minimality definitely has because it
gives you much clearer picture right
because otherwise all those chords
gigantic you can't say much
just to remark that I have no idea
what's a high quality coil like Stefan
refers to for example we have unit core
well okay like all small disjoint
courses are always good and they're good
for uh finding uh at most one
so yeah everything is made here it's
just for us I just wanted to say that
right so it's it's we don't even sort of
know
what we want to find
that's why now we're trying to find
everything we can
okay so we have to finish right yes uh
sorry we have to finish so okay another
question uh we have a question so um in
model checking there are algorithms
which are based on on course like
abstraction refinement so you find the
quora then you continue with that core
but it's not it's not immediately clear
which core is is the best like you you
can determine maybe empirically but but
then don't think being the best in this
I think is super super important because
we have to look at to solve max out you
have to relax all the chords good and
bad right uh
okay uh let's thank Nina twice
[Applause]